hey love it's me I know you said you
wanted some space
but I miss you
a lot
[Music]
I just wanted to let you know that I
will be coming
I'm gonna hit the road and I should be
there in a couple of days
it's been a long time since I've seen
them
oh
so happy that you're here ready
this is Monica
hi hey your mother she doesn't know who
I am
[Music]
I don't know what I would do if I
couldn't be with my own mom at A Moment
Like This
you gotta say I never would have
recognized you
whatever is happening is
family comes first
I know you told me not to call but um I
just need to talk
I can no longer be your mother
she said to me
[Music]
it's been very tough around here
when are you going to tell her
[Applause]
what's your name please remind me
Monica